hey youtubers is Charlie happy
Valentine's Day since Hannibal is coming
back really soon and I thought it was
time to do a big preview for season two
because there's been a lot of changes
since season one I will be doing weekly
videos for each episode whenever it
comes back it's gonna be a Friday show
this year it'll be 13 episodes total be
sure to subscribe to get everything if
you are finding me for the first time so
let's break things down this way first
I'll talk about the characters and then
I'll talk about the episodes one of the
coolest things about Hannibal is that
each episode corresponds to this really
gourmet meal everybody grab your Forks
and let's dig in the biggest change from
season 1 is obviously the reversal of
Hannibal Lecter with will Graham will is
institutionalized like Hannibal will be
eventually and Hannibal has taken wills
job consulting with the FBI
based on the trailer it looks like
they're not wasting any time and someone
else learning the truth about Hannibal
being the real serial killer the image
of him attacking Laurence Fishburne with
the knife was one of the first things
they released one of the big issues I
had with the trailer though is the idea
that it could all be unreliable
narration a lot of last season was spent
debating on whether or not will Graham
was hallucinating things and whether or
not his memories were false
I don't think Bryan Fuller would pull a
huge fake out on the trailer so I do
think that Hannibal will end up trying
to kill Jack Crawford unless they
deviate from the original canon he's
still alive during Silence of the Lambs
which means that he won't end up dying
this season the big arc of season 2
though is will Graham coming after
Hannibal with a vengeance I really love
how the show finds ways to mirror
imagery from Silence of the Lambs
especially with the finale so think of
will Graham right now is like the
Anthony Hopkins character helping the
FBI catch Hannibal who's kind of like
the Buffalo Bill I don't think he's
gonna be making any people skin suits
though a lot of the early episodes of
this season though will have to deal
with will getting Elana Beverly Abrams
and Crawford to believe him again I had
to say though of all the supporting
characters my favorite you know aside
from Gillian Anderson who's just
flat-out amazing is Scott Thompson Hugh
Dancy said that when they're on set
Scott makes them laugh so hard even when
they're filming the bloodiest of scenes
every time I see him on screen all I can
think about is kids in the hall though
it's so hilarious one of the best parts
of Hannibal I think is that you know how
the story is going to end so Bryan
Fuller in the cast delight and allowing
things to unfold in these really
fascinating ways style and
cinematography are a huge part of the
show too which is a good intro to the
episode titles I'm just gonna do a
breakdown of all the episode title
and what they mean so everybody open
your cookbooks to page 1 episode 1 is
titled Cacique which is actually a meta
term it's both a multi-course Japanese
meal and it refers to the types of
skills necessary to prepare high level
cuisines this is actually where things
get really interesting
all the episode titles this season are
titles of the different courses of this
qussuk a meal so think of season two is
like one single meal with 13 different
courses right now we only know details
on eight of those 13 episodes but since
each of the titles derives from these 13
different courses we can kind of guess
what the missing ones are so we don't
know the official titles for episodes
two or three but episode four is titled
taka was--a this course is actually
vegetables served with meat episode five
is titled mukou zu k this course is a
slice dish of sashimi Brian fuller
actually posted a picture from the
editing Bay of Hannibal swimming episode
six is called food Emoto it's a soup
dish and there's another
behind-the-scenes picture of Mads in it
Episode seven is called yakamoto
it's actually a flame-broiled dish
served in pottery episode eight is
called Sousa Kanna it's a course that's
meant to be a palate cleanser like
vegetables and vinegar episode nine is
titled she's the kinda this course is a
really big dish served in a hot pot it
kind of implies something really big is
gonna be happening in this episode we
don't know anything about episode ten
but episode eleven is called ko no mo no
it's a dish of pickled vegetables we
don't know anything about the final two
episodes either but like I said you know
all these different titles derived from
this Cacique meal so we can kind of
guess what the remaining episode titles
are going to be sach uzuki is called the
appetizer so I don't think they'll use
this title because they already have the
episode 1 title Hassoun is the second
course which implies they'll use it for
episode 2 Hayashi bocce is another one
of the dishes and it's only served
during this summer but it's just another
vegetable course knockout choko is
another course it's also a palate
cleanser Gohan is a rice dish Toma Wan
is a miso based soup dish and the only
other course that they haven't used as
an episode title is called Mizumoto it's
the dessert course but like I said the
only one of those that I listed that I
don't think they're gonna use is the
appetizer dish as the episodes start
I'll discuss the relevance of each title
to the meal and the story in each
episode though that's one of the really
cool stylistic touches of Hannibal
is that the title tends to imply what
the action of the episodes going to be
they also tell you what those literal
meals that Hannibal will be preparing
during the episode are which are both
amazing to look at and make you sick at
the same time so my next Hannibal video
will be next Friday I'll do my top 5
moments from season 1 be sure to
subscribe to get it it's gonna be a lot
of fun happy Valentine's Day to you all
whether you're cooking something or
someone right now click here for my Game
of Thrones foreshadowing breakdown and
click here for my Walking Dead episode 9
review thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives